[Music]
what's up fellow Geeks we have 19 in of
Venom ready for you in this Spider-Man 2
collector's edition just look at this
thing
it's this is
beautiful look at that you got
Spider-Man logo on the side we got all
this stuff that's coming right for you
in the back here we got a steelbook
obviously digital version of the game
the 19 in of Venom complete with Miles
Morales and Peter Parker and of course
digital content which obviously you know
we can't be showing that so with that
let's just get into this unboxing just
got to kind of lift it up
here like that it is quite tight oh my
God here
we go all right friendo this is how the
box and the inside looks like we got
little flaps on the side here to remove
the top cover so let's do just that got
to lay flat on the ground and let us
reveal what's on the inside oh wa
where's the other side okay so you got
two
sides all
right o okay the first thing you'll see
is a steelbook case and let's open it up
and it's beautiful this thing is kind of
it's not textured at all it's not
bumping out it's just that the back is
glossy and the characters are just matte
so there the little distinction here but
other than that let's flip it over and
you get your codes for the digital
Deluxe content Edition and pre-order
bonuses right here this is how the
inside looks like nothing much and yeah
of course it's a digital version so it's
a steelbook without a CD the next thing
we have on the inside is a pamphlet to
teach us how to build the Statue so
let's just get down to that let's open
this up very nice rig
packaging and
O all
right this is how it looks like in the
Box Peter Parker over here is separate
so be careful he will pop off pretty
easy Miles Morales is attached here and
I don't think you can remove him and
Venom your boy so let's just take this
out
move everyone all right more plastic
packaging and I believe there's
something else inside here according to
the pamphlet little string thingy on
here which is right here so be careful
I'm going to remove this real quick
let's just open this all right this
thing is oh it's metal so there's a
little hole right here which I'll show
and just kind of plunk it in there and
this will keep Peter Parker up in the
air just like that so oh my God that is
quite the image here and seeing is full
Glory I man I I I don't I think this is
one of the best collector editions we've
seen so far this whole thing is 19 in
let me just go get a measuring tape real
quick and the only way it does reach 19
or sort of 19 is with Miles Morales over
here even with Parker it isn't that tall
but with
miles it kind of hits the mark look at
Venom's teeth here it may or may not
been put in a mle but it does look
natural enough there are random little
gaps here and there some are clumped up
some are not but it looks good enough
from AAR and even a little close up but
not too close obviously and his tongue
over here it's obviously all stuck in
there but it looks really good with all
the little glazing here and there so it
makes for a very believable wet tongue I
look at Venom's eyes and the muscle
details and everything over here these
look really good I don't see any like
sort of mle lines or anything the stream
of webbing down here is made of metal
and it runs pretty deep into his
shoulder rest assur that petker won't be
falling off anytime soon and this bit on
here that attaches to his wrist does Run
Deep in as well so it's very secure and
with Ms Morales even though it does kind
of look like there's points of
articulation down here there really
isn't it's like a nice little mole line
down here that I kind of wish they
covered up but from afar looks pretty
good but it's the case for most CES I
mean obviously you're not getting a hot
toys level collectible out of a c so I
can't live with that M Morales still
looks pretty good from afar and if I
pull this out really
quickly and you just see this beauty of
a statue this thing looks amazing anyway
let me know if you guys are getting this
C for yourselves and if you have it
already let me know what you guys think
of it in the comment section below hell
if you're planning to get it let me know
as well if you like what we do follow
follow on all of our socials right here
to keep up to date with the stuff we
post daily and if you like what you're
watching and want to see more maybe hit
the like And subscribe buttons it helps
us out a lot anyway this is z have a
great week and I'll catch youall
[Applause]
[Music]
soon